que nunca antes van a votar desde
lugares como este desde la sala de su
cocina ejerciendo su derecho fundamental
desde casa pero a pesar de lo que ha
dicho el presidente votar por mí por el
correo ha sido algo seguro durante
décadas en 2016 33 millones de
estadounidenses votaron por correo
incluso donald trump pidió un voto en
ausencia dos veces este año así que esta
vez muchos van a decidir votar de manera
presencial con una mascarilla mientras
que muchos otros votaremos por correo
aquí en nevada
seguimos los consejos de los expertos y
escuchamos a las personas de nevada para
establecer un sistema de voto por email
por correo para que la gente tenga
opciones pero yo no choque está tratando
de dividirnos dañando ese derecho
está amenazando con retirar fondos a
nevada y eso está financiando nuestras
escuelas y en nuestros nuestros puestos
a la tercera pero nosotros
hemos pedido a los jueces que no
escuchen esta petición y está poniendo
la vida de personas en riesgo al atacar
al sistema postal lo que significa que
muchos personas versadas no pueden
recibir sus medicinas porque él quiere
ganar una elección bueno señor
presidente no estamos intimidados por
usted estados unidos no está intimidada
por usted estamos unidos por valores
compartidos por una historia compartida
y por los derechos compartidos
incluyendo nuestro derecho fundamental
al voto y vamos a enviar a joe biden a
la casa blanca y vamos a voltear el
senador sacando a mis manos del poder y
con una mayoría demócrata en el senado
vamos a expandir estos derechos al voto
y a protegerlos y para hacerlo
necesitamos que están de nuestro lado
así que vayan a el show baidu.com en
este momento para aportar y ayúdenos a
cambiar el senado
para recuperar la cámara alta donald
trump y mitch mcconnell saben como
dividirnos pero nosotros sabemos como
mantenernos unidos y cambiar la
situación